right welcome back to the course on
finite and algorithmic model theory part
two I say automata based methods I've
I'll start with a little wrap-up of what
we did yesterday so I said in finite
model theory we're aiming to develop
tools for studying the expressive power
of logic in finite structures and I
noted that the relation of elementary
equivalence which is sort of the
fundamental relation in classical model
theory that one studies is in a sense
trivial not in the computational sense
on finite structures in the sense that
it coincides with isomorphism so it
doesn't tell us anything about define
ability as such and as a consequence
every property of finite structures is
definable by a first order theory so to
study define ability in the finite we
stratify this relation of elementary
colin's and the we looked at two
stratifications one by quantifier rank
and the other by number of variables and
each of these has a nice
characterization in terms of spoiler
duplicator games which i mean it's just
in some ways a reformulation of the of
the equivalence but it gives us a nice
perspicuous way of describing it and
using these equivalences and we use
these games to show that some properties
are not definable by first-order
sentences connectivity to color ability
and some are not even xima ties about by
finite number variables so you know
infinite set of sentences but using a
finite number of variables we still
can't do even this existence of a
perfect matching in a graph
hamiltonicity right these were examples
that came up
and then I concluded with a handful
Akala T theorem which shows that
structures that look locally the same
are not distinguished by first order
formulas so I want to get back to this
and I've given the cleaned-up
formulation which I kind of referred to
while I having that messy formulation up
on the on the board so I'll state it a
little bit more cleanly now say an BR
handful covalent with radius R if
there's a bijection between the elements
of a and the elements of B which takes a
point a to a point in B so that the
neighborhood in a of this point is
isomorphic to the neighborhood its image
in B neighborhood of radius R and the
theorem is that there is a radius once
you fix the vocabulary and you fix the
quantify rank there is a radius so that
if two structures are half the covalent
with that radius then they're
indistinguishable by any first order
formula with quantify rank P and we can
use this to revisit some of the proofs
of inexpressible ax T we did and they
kind of become very easy to see you know
you can just give a picture in a sense
and show it so my example of
connectivity into colorability remember
two cycles in one cycle
they weren't hands equivalent simply
because they had different sizes because
I was using the same example for
evenness so I had to times to the P on
one side to the P plus one on the other
so there's no by ejection so in the way
I've defined handful colons they were
not but for leave of a even as for a
connectivity and to caller ability I can
choose a cycle and two cycles so that
these two add up to the same length but
make it big enough so that when you look
at the neighborhood of any point it just
looks like a simple line and so you know
any by ejection between them will
actually you know map neighborhoods to
isomorphic neighborhoods okay so
immediately from this illustration you
see and the Hans theorem you get that
connectivity into colorability are not
definable asic lissa T is not definable
just take that
ruff versus this graph choose the sizes
so that they match up and again you have
a bisection between them sort of the
neighborhood matchup you just need to
make sure that things close to the
endpoints are mapped close to the
endpoints by this projection and things
in the middle get mapped to this over
here so that the neighborhood
neighborhood look the same okay here's
an illustration showing that planarity
is not definable by first-order logic so
what I've done is take a five-click and
imagine you replace every edge by a long
path and here I've taken the same graph
but instead of these two long paths I
have these two long parts this is a
planar graph this is you know because
it's a subdivision of a five-click it's
not a planar graph but there is I mean
the neighborhood of any element locally
looks exactly the same in the two graphs
okay to me this has something of this
flavor of the s you're drawing that
Sampson was showing us yesterday you
know locally this thing is very planar
it's indistinguishable from that it's
when you put it all together you know
and you go around the loop but it kind
of falls apart okay so that's hams
locality theorem another locality
theorem very commonly used and in
tomorrow's lecture we'll be looking at
some uses of this these guys my sermons
which is in some sense stronger and that
you can derive the handful version from
it so the key thing is in enhanced
theorem you're looking at maybe hoods of
points and you're looking at the
isomorphism types of those neighborhoods
- serum is in in a sense says instead of
looking at the isomorphism types it's
enough to look at what happens
what first-order formulas are true in
the neighborhood but you have to you
know it's it's not quite than just
matching up neighborhoods by oh by
ejection so let me just state the
theorem it's in first order logic you
can say you can write down a formula
with two free variables x and y which
says that the distance between points x
and y is say greater than d and I write
Delta X Y is greater than B as shorthand
for that formula ok it's easy to write
we sort of did something we did
something similar when we defined
connectivity so that'll be piece of
notation so say I'm a formula with a
free variable X I write sy n where if n
is some definable set u relativize all
the quantifiers in sy by that set so
you're a place there exists X right
there exists X inside the set n such
that and so on so basically it says that
whatever UPS I assert holds true within
the set N and we're going to what we're
going to do is relativize formulas to
the neighborhood around the point and so
we say a basic local sentence is one of
this for the following form it exists
asserts the existence of s points which
were pair pair wise far apart right I've
written to R here so basically are
saying that there are neighborhoods of
these points are disjoint and says that
each one of them satisfies the for the
neighborhood there are neighborhood
around each one satisfies the formula
sorry ok so a basic local sentence is
just an assertion that there exists some
set of points which are with disjoint
neighborhoods and something is true in
all of these neighborhoods and guys my
serum basically says that's pretty much
you what you can do in first order logic
any first order sentence is equivalent
to a boolean combination
of basic local sentences okay so this is
the sort of strong locality print
principle of first order logic I'm not
going to give you a proof of this this
is rather convoluted argument yeah
that's why I
in other words SCI is no it's it's one
formula exactly the same well not
exactly yeah and we're a certain one
force or a formula that holds in all
these neighborhoods but ultimately it's
a boolean combination of these so you
can write so um
that's right
okay and there's two on all structures
this is nothing to do with the
finiteness okay I'll come back to I mean
in some sense this is the point at which
I intended to get to at the at the end
of the first lecture a discussion of
locality and I'll come back to uses of
this in then in the next lecture right
now I want to say a few things that kind
of follow from this characterizations of
these stratified elementary quadrants
we've been looking at so you have a pair
of structures the disjoint some of the
structures all right or disjoint Union
is simply the structure you take get by
taking the disjoint union of the
universes and let interpret each
relation as the union of the two
relations so they're really just you
know two structures unconnected in any
way with each other form into one
structure now we can say if you have a
pair of structures which are P
equivalent a1 and a2 and similarly B 1
and B 2 are P equivalent then the
disjoint union of a1 and b1 is P
equivalent to the disjoint union of a2
and b2 in other words this P equivalence
is a congruence with respect to this
disjoint sum operation and the argument
is obvious when you think of it as a
game you have a structure where you have
this a 1 and B 1 and you have the
disjoint summoned or not there's no
relations that connect them and on the
other side you have a 2 and B 2 and we
know that duplicator has a winning
strategy restricted to these two
structures and a winning strategy
restricted to these two structures so
you combine the winning strategies
simply by saying whenever spoiler plays
in an element of a1 respond according to
the winning strategy between a1 and a2
whenever spoiler plays on one of these
you respond according to the winning
strategy restricted to those two and
it's easy to see that this combined
strategy defines the winning strategy
for duplicator on these ok and the same
argument holds for the K equivalence
relation
so superscript K meaning if you count
the number of variables again if there's
a winning strategy on the unbounded game
in K variables do an a1 and a2 and
similarly B would be one NB - there's a
winning strategy on the combined
structure by just composing the two
don't seem unsure okay the point is
there's fewer than K on anyone and we
know duplicator has a winning strategy
okay okay so that's disjoint sum but
there's other ways we can combine
structures suppose for instance we had a
pair of structure is where the
vocabulary includes a binary relation
which is interpreted as a linear order
of the structure these are ordered
structures okay I'm going to find the
ordered sum of a and B as the structure
which is the disjoint union of the
universes again for all relations other
than the order you again take the
disjoint union of the the relations for
the order you are you take the Union but
you also say that every element of a
comes before every element of B right so
you now again have a linearly ordered
structure okay and exactly the same
argument works right that the duplicator
has a winning strategy on a1 and a2 and
b1 and b2 duplicator has a winning
strategy on the combined one because the
only thing that links these two is the
order and the strategy always plays if
what one element is less than over here
less than another one over here that
property is preserved so the combined
strategy is to the winning strategy on
the order of some so this relation is a
congruence also with respect to order
terms
okay and again this holds for okay
slightly slight variation on the some
suppose we have two structures and their
universes intersect in a set X okay
I define the sum over X to be the
structure whose universe is the union of
a and B so now there's not the disjoint
Union there is a set X which is common
and all relations are the Union over n
being the union of the common relations
so think of it this way as a picture
it's more like we have a structure a and
we have a structure B and we're keeping
the points X in common and now any tuple
which is in a relation of course all the
elements are either in a or all of them
in B those you know some a some of those
elements may be in both in B right
that's the structure which I call the
sum of a and B over X now what can we
say about this say combining strategies
if you have a 1 and a 2 and B 1 and B 2
and you take the sum over X it's not so
obvious
actually we can I'm I mean for the P
equivalence let me just say right so
what we say is the following if there's
a winning strategy between a1 and a2
which on the subset X in a1 and the
subset why are they to always you know
as a where you always match elements of
X with elements of Y what maybe I should
say this a bit more killing
we haven't structurally we expand it
with new constants and maim every
element of X by a constant symbol so
this means that this in this P
equivalents in any winning strategy
every element of X will have to map to a
corresponding element of Y always right
that the map on x and y is fixed because
you've named them by constants ok I'm
just writing this is an expansion of a
by set of constants now a1 is the
structure with a set X a2 is another
structure with a set Y of constants and
say these are P equivalent and these are
P equivalent b1 and b2 you take the sum
of a1 and b1 over X and the sum of a2
and b2 over Y these are also P
equivalent right in other words because
that's right so the point is we have a 1
sorry a 1 B 1 and we have a 2 B 2 and
they said why right and we want to
conclude that conclusion that these two
are P equivalent it's not enough to
assume that a a 1 is P equivalent to a 2
and B 1 is P equal to P 2 you have to
assume that the strategy B 1 a 1 a day
two respects X&Y in some sense to be
able to to form the composition of the
strategies that's what this assumption
is saying
then you name all the elements effects
and all the elements of Y and if you
have a strategy which respects that then
you can combine these two strategies to
get a strategy on the combined structure
isn't that too strong an assumption I
mean is it necessary to know I mean
you're necessarily you can come up with
example I mean can you formulate a
weaker condition yes sorry you could
certainly make weaker assumptions yes
strategies that's right structures
themselves right now the strategies you
just thought say them whatever they do
an X Y duplicator responded Y or
interesting and will respond the same
way of whether it uses this the AIDS or
the HIV strategy exactly that seems to
be what's really needed to that's right
that's a condition of strategy is not on
the structures
so
so I'm going to come back again to two
using this in a moment I'm sort of
building up the machinery I want to say
a little bit about second-order logic
because it seems a good point so we've
talked about first-order logic so far
second-order logic is the extension with
quantifiers over relations so we can now
say there exists an X where X is a
relation symbol right of RTM and this is
true and and of course then we can use
it inside Phi as a relation symbol and
this is true in a structure if the there
it can be expanded by a memory relation
interpreting this to make file true okay
and I write Sigma 1 1 for the
existential fragment of second order
logic that is those formulas of
second-order logic written which written
in pre next normal form have existential
quantifiers in the front followed by Phi
a first-order formula muriatic
second-order logic is those formulas a
second-order logic in which all the
relational quantifiers are over unary
relation so they're over sets rather
than arbitrary relations and again we
can put it any MSO formula in pre next
normal form the second-order quantifiers
preceding first-order ones and I'll
write monadic Sigma 1 1 for those
formulas which in pre next normal form
have only exist enchilada fires and
menardi PI 1 1 for those formulas where
it's in pre next normal form have only
universal quantifiers ok now what do I
want to say about this
this is an example I showed you before 3
colorability which is not definable
in first order logic I didn't prove that
to you but given the tools we've
developed you can easily do this and I
showed you that it's definable by a
monadic sigma11 formula connectivity
right I showed you is not first-order
definable it's easily definable by a
monic pi11 formula so this says that a
graph is connected because it says that
for every set of vertices you take if
it's non empty and it's closed under the
edge relation then it contains
everything ok so that's just saying that
the graph is connected it's not
connectivity is not definable by monadic
sigma11 sentence this was a result
already in Fagin's c thesis in 1974 and
you could prove it by an application of
hands localities here even though houses
locality theorem was about first-order
logic because what it is is you take a
cycle of length 2 N and the disjoint
union of two cycles of length n and we
know these are harmful covalent if n is
big enough with respect to the radius
but you can say Oh something more you
can show that take any coloring of this
any color the cycle see 2n in any way if
n is big enough then you can find a
coloring of this which is P equivalent
right so there the neighborhood's with
respect to radius P look the same ok
it's just n has to be enormous Liebig
for for this to work for any coloring ok
that's so this means that if you could
define connectivity whereby an
existential monadic signal on one
sentence that sentence would be true you
take the interpretation of the
existential quantifiers which makes it
true take that as your coloring repeat
the coloring over here and you know that
you have the two things are first-order
equivalent up to quantify rank P
and that's a contradiction because the
second graph is disconnected okay
so you can't do this with melodic
sigma11 sentence color in fact why you
can find this coloring I mean it's just
a sort of in some sense a pigeonhole
argument if n is big enough then you
have repeated patterns of you know
length P there are only finitely many
you'll find lots of repeated patterns
some pattern will occur frequently
enough that you get two points with the
same pattern around them which are
exactly distant apart if you know if you
if you make em big enough and then you
just essentially think of splitting the
N cycle I mean if you have
if you have a big end cycle right
colored in such a way and you find two
points over here so which are exactly
distance and apart and their
neighborhoods look the same you
essentially think of this as coloring
two n cycles
with exactly the same colors and the
neighborhood look exactly the same but
this is this was this one this was
Fagin's original argument the revised
version by RIT and Faen allowed you to
choose the the length of these two
cycles dependent on the coloring but
that requires another argument for why
that that's valid and and I wanted to
avoid that here yes so we I think what
you're saying is yeah so this
connectedness is monadic sigma11 that's
what this is but connectedness is not
where you are seems to be describing
this formula right okay
right so so this is an application of
Hansel comedy theorem to get an
inexpressible 'ti result for from erotic
second or logic or the existential
fragment we can also extend the game we
define two metallics second-order logic
right being as I saying oh because I
realize I say am there but I've been
using P all along and there might be a
inconsistency later but anyway we have a
spoiler duplicate a game between two
plate on two structures a and B and at
each stage now spoiler can either make a
point move or a set move right in a
point move spoiler chooses an element as
before and duplicate or I sort of
respond with an element of the other
structure in a set move spoiler chooses
a subset a certain say s1 on one side
and duplicator has to respond with a set
in the other structure right this
corresponds to the quantification over
sets
and if after M rounds you look at the
structures expanded with the relations
with the sets that have been chosen and
this the map defined by the elements
that have been chosen is a partial
isomorphism then duplicator has won the
game
right so duplicator has to preserve that
not just partial isomorphism on the
original structures but expanded with
the sets that were chosen during the
game okay it's exactly analogous to what
we had before we define quantifier rank
exactly by adding the additional rule
that we count set quantifiers just as we
counted ordinary quantifiers and we have
the equivalence between this game and
equivalents in MSO up the quantifier
rank P okay I'm not going to sort of
argue this much further this is mainly
let me introduce a bit of notation for
structure a right type M SOA for the set
of all sentences with quantifier rank
less than P that satisfied again up to
logical equivalence there are finitely
many such sentences once you've
restricted the quantifier rank and
you're in a finite vocabulary and we
write two things our MSOP equivalent if
they if the types are the same they
satisfy the same sentences okay
so yes I just said this so this relation
has finite index and moreover we can
find a single sentence that
characterizes this type as as we had
before so having defined the game so
just as I showed you this P colons in
the congruence the same thing sort of
follows for this MSO game right because
now the only thing to consider there is
the set move so spoiler chooses a subset
of disjoint union of a1 and b1 do that
decomposes into a subset of a1 and a
subset of v1 you look at the response in
the two separate strategies and you take
the Union okay and this worked for order
sums and also sums over a set X again in
the sense of you know having the
expansion with the with the constant and
here I want to stress I mean I could
also define I defined the game for MI so
I could you could also define a game for
second-order logic where spoiler gets to
choose an arbitrary relation and
duplicator has to respond with the
relation in the other structure but then
then this really doesn't work for the
simple reason that a spoiler move played
on a structure like this takes a
relation of these and a relation over
the disjoint union of a and B doesn't
decompose into a relation on a inter
relation on B because there it relates
elements of a with relevance of B okay
so this this kind of thing doesn't work
if you go beyond muriatic second-order
logic right what makes it work is that
these sets decompose into their
individual parts moreover you can show
that here plus is any one of these sums
you can actually compute given the types
of the tool of a and B you can get the
type of the some structure and I'm not
going to tell you why it'll take me too
far but and I mean I don't need the
computability
a woman but this is just an observation
okay so now I'm going to talk a little
bit about strings what do I mean by
strings I'm by strings I mean structures
which have one binary relation which is
a linear order the universe and some
collection of Uri relations so a
structure like this is linearly ordered
structure and you have unary relation so
I can think of this as a word over an
alphabet
well the alphabet is the power set of
you right so for each element you take
the set of elements of U which are true
of it right so if I have any relations
this corresponds to a string in enough
in an alphabet with two n letters to
assign two to the N letters
and okay I call it everything view here
I'll go talk about the the beauty I'll
go talking about theorem is much more
than this right but I'm just taking one
bit of it so if you have a sentence of
MSL this says that the language
consisting of those strings which
satisfy fine and by that I mean in this
sense right you take structures with a
linear order over a fixed alphabet then
this language is regular I say it's much
stronger because of course there's a
converse as well I think it's right okay
I don't see it there's a converse right
any regular language okay you know you
can translate it for any regular
language you can define an MSO sentence
that's in some sense you can do a direct
translation from finite automaton right
and of course the theorem also extends
to infinity rings etc but I just want to
look at this this direction for finite
strings have you got a particularly
perspicuous proof using the my held
around theorem right H my hair or
theorem is something I did as an
undergraduate automata Theory course
it's something I I find very familiar if
you if you don't know it the milder or
theorem says you have an arbitrary
equivalence relation on strings we call
it's a right invariant if whatever two
strings are equivalent appending the
same string to them gives you
equivalence rings right relation is
right invariant and the my holder or
theorem says a language is regular if
and only if it is the union of
equivalence classes of some right
invariant equivalence relation of finite
index
and this is kind of immediate from the
translation into finite automata and now
all I need to note is if you have a
formula of msl and it has quantifier
rank P then the language it defines is
invariant under this equivalence
relation necessarily this relation has
finite index we've argued that because
it's you know they're only finitely many
different formulas and it is right
invariant by the fact that this relation
is a congruence for ordered some and so
any language you can define is
necessarily regular
and here's an interesting use of this
I'll show you that there is no formula
of hair missile no sense of a missile in
the language of graph that defines the
collection of Hamiltonian graphs okay so
now this is nothing about strings this
is just an ordinary question about
define ability of mi7 graphs
suppose we had such a formula right
which defined Hamiltonian graph school
now I define a formula Phi prime by just
replacing every occurrence of the edge
relation inside v by the following
relation in a vocabulary with to unity
relations a and B it just says ax and B
Y or B X and ay Y okay so I replace in
Phi this by this formula what do I get I
get a formula Phi prime which if you
interpret it on a string it says that
the graph you get in the complete sorry
that the graph the complete bipartite
graph you get by putting all A's on one
side all B's on the other side and
putting all the edges between them is
Hamiltonian right that's what the
formula Phi prime says but a complete
bipartite graph is Hamiltonian if and
only if the two sides have the same
number of vertices right to construct a
Hamiltonian graph in a bipartite a come
to construct a Hamiltonian cycle in a
complete bipartite graph if you start at
one end and cross over each Edge has to
take you to the other side to complete
the cycle you have to cross exactly the
same number of times so this is not a
Hamiltonian cycle therefore this formula
Phi prime is true in a string if and
only if it has an equal number of A's
and B's this is not a regular language
and therefore this is impossible
so
I like this example because you know in
terms of building up rules for proving
an extra 70 right we have our Aaron Fox
games we have the locality theorems and
this basically says the pumping lemma is
also a useful tool for proving an
express ability of in logic okay well as
I said in in Albert's talk we'll get to
0 $1 as well the point is it you can
make it I mean so the statement of our
world order structure is stronger and
it's still true ok but all I'm saying is
suppose there's a formula which defines
Hamiltonian cycles even without an order
I mean assuming ok if there is one which
defines a with an order this still works
replacing X Y by this it's you know an
MSL
sentence in an ordered language which
still defines the set of strings with an
equal number of A's and B's so you got a
contradiction right doing it without an
order is a weaker statement that's still
true right
um
so now that was strings now I'm going to
talk a little bit about automata or
trees because they the connection
between MSL and and finite automata
extends in this and as I said there's a
the I mean I mentioned briefly on the
slide there's a there's a rich theory
that goes in this direction of which I'm
I'm only illustrating methods with the
illustrative results which is what I
said I was doing in this course so far
as a routed directed tree is a directed
graph so you have one binary relation
well with a distinguished root so you
have a constant a and for every vertex
feed there is a path from there's a
unique directed path from A to B okay
that's right we might consider things
expanded with the traditional unary
relation so we get coloured routed
director trees and so on now I'm going
to define certain operations on these
rotate directed trees given ta I define
our TA to be the directed tree which is
essentially
you take the original a and you add a
new roots to it and you make that the
root of your director tree okay
I'll make the observation that the type
in MSL after quite a variety of this
thing is determined entirely by the type
over over here well
boy
okay let me carry on now you get any
rooted directory tree by starting with
some single node trees right and
repeated applications of the operation
of adding a root and taking the sum over
the root right so this is the sum of
those structures where we identify the
roots its disjoint some what identifying
the roots and you can build up any tree
by a sequence of these operations
so from an MSO formula we can translate
it into a bottom-up tree otamatone
essentially working on this if you will
the parse tree of our rooted directory
tree using these operations which
computes the type of the whole tree
right in other words the states are the
equivalence classes MSO P where P and
you get a man's and peas mixed up at
some point but P is the quantifier rank
of Phi and their transitions in the
automaton corresponding to the two
operations right of rooted some of this
joy of sum over a and adding a root and
so this is a tree automatron so you know
it involves about you know this binary
operation and the accepting states are
exactly those classes that satisfy Phi
in other words those types that include
Phi okay what if this dude this allows
us to translate any formula famous all
into an automaton just like you know we
had on strings and we're going to extend
this
one step further okay so and I'm gonna
look at graphs now undirected graphs in
general of bounded tree width now I know
many of you are familiar with free
weights but I assume not everybody is so
the tree width of an undirected graph is
a measure of how tree like the structure
is right in associate with every graph
there is a measure called it's tree
width it's the more interconnected the
graph the more unlike a tree essentially
the higher the tree width trees have
small treatment the trees have tree
width one okay and I'll show you
examples of graphs of higher tree wait
at the moment but the intuition is
before I give you a formal definition a
graph has tree with K if it can be
covered by sub graphs of at most k plus
1 nodes in a tree like fashion so here
the black nodes and lines represent the
graph the blue blobs are subsets which
cover the whole graph the blue blobs are
connected in a tree-like fashion I can
make this precise and the largest blob
has four nodes in it so this shows that
that black graph there has tree with
three because it can be covered by
subsets of sub graphs of size four in
this tree right equation okay and this
covering is what we call a tree
decomposition of a graph formally
speaking
we have a graph the tree decomposition
associates to that graph a treaty okay
and we have a relation which basically
assigns to every element of T a set of
vertices okay so I just call that a real
I mean it's just a relation between the
vertices of the graph and the nodes of
the tree which satisfies certain
conditions for each B this set I should
say is non-empty right every vertex in
the graph is associated naanum some
non-empty set of nodes in the tree and
that set of nodes is a connected sub
tree of T so you can't have the same
vertex appearing in two nodes in the
tree without appearing everywhere on the
on the path in between right
and every edge in the graph is covered
by some node there is a node in the tree
that's that both U and V are associated
to it it doesn't know T okay so this is
sort of maybe if you've seen this for
the first time difficult definition to
get your head around keep the picture I
had on the previous slide in mind that's
what that that's really what this is
doing and then the tree width is the
smallest number so that we can find a
tree decomposition for the graph where
the set of nodes associate set of
vertices of the graph associated with
any node of the tree has size at most k
plus 1 okay so trees I said have tree
with 1 why is this well actually so if
you have a tree and you want to cover it
with
give a tree decomposition what are going
to be the nodes of your tree
decomposition each node has to every
edge has to appear inside an order the
tree decomposition but that's pretty
much all you really need to do
right so the nodes of the tree
decomposition really correspond to the
edges and you can see so this one
appears in these four okay but they're
connected okay well I haven't exactly
told you what the sorry I know one about
sorry yes in the five and it and these
form a connected part of the red tree
okay so this is why trees are free with
one and this is why we have that k plus
one in the definition right why you why
you count the number number of nodes
minus one because trees really should
have tree with one rather than two if
you have a cycle in a graph sorry your
graph is a cycle I should say so
it has free weights too because you can
cover it with sets of size three there's
various ways you can do this here's one
I'll start with that set of size three
no note because this vertex in some
sense both these edges are covered I can
forget about it I don't need it anymore
so as my next one I'll take that
okay now this vertex has had both of its
edges covered I don't need it anymore so
for my third one I'll take that set size
three in this one in this one and then
that one and my tree is really there for
something which looks like a simple line
it's a path okay weak you can't cover
except by taking all the elements into a
single set and so a cake-like has tree
with K minus one and a grid by grid I
just mean
and okay the tree width is the minimum
of the to deny two dimensions okay
you do something similar to what you do
to the cycle your bags consist of let's
say here let's say this is the smaller
dimension you take this and one of those
and then you can drop this and take the
rest of these and the next one
etc taking sets of size n plus one at a
time you can cover the whole thing okay
of course I'm claiming here not just
that you have decomposition of this
width but those are optimal you can't do
better than that and that of course
requires rather more proof but that's
true in each of these cases so why I
mean tree width is something that been
widely studied in the well first in
graph structure theory and then in the
algorithmic world because it sort of
turns out to be a very useful way of
parameterizing algorithms and basically
the sense of faces graphs a small tree
with that made efficient dynamic
programming algorithms for problems
which are otherwise intractable given a
graph with a tree decomposition you can
essentially work your algorithm
bottom-up along this tree decomposition
and combine results and at any point you
as you come up bottom-up you only have a
small intersection with the with the
results of computer before and in that
as I said by essentially a dynamic
programming approach you can capture all
the information you need to sort of
recursively work on the graphs right
it's you have algorithms that work
recursively on the tree structure and
these small sets because they bound the
size of the intersection of your trees
basically limit the amount of
information you need to collect from the
recursive calls as you go up
so that's at any stage a small set of
vertices from the interface to the rest
of the graph that's the the essentials
of what a tree decomposition does so
trying to formalize this we can say you
look at the decomposition bottom-up what
you have is a graph of tree Witzke when
once you have the decomposition is
obtained from graphs with at most k plus
1 nodes through a finite sequence of
application of the operation of taking
sums over sets of at most K elements
what do I mean by sums over sets I mean
exactly the thing we had before right
the operation of taking a sum where the
intersection of the two graphs has at
most K elements okay and you identify
these so this is the the sum of G 1 and
G 2 over set X
so in this tree decomposition going
bottom-up you would start with these two
sets and take the thumb over their
intersection which is this you now have
a set with three elements right a graph
with three elements and you take it some
with this one identifying this just this
one element right you have this graph
with four you take it some with this one
identifying this take it some of this
one I don't define that somewhere this
one identify that etc okay
at each point you are identifying one
element and this generalizes laboratory
kay that's what a tree decomposition
gives you okay so if TK is the class of
graphs with tree with it most clearly
I mean when I introduced this operation
of disjoint sum over a set I said we we
have constants for these elements so
let's make this explicit start with
graphs which have let's say expanded
weight with k plus 1 constant see it's
easier up to see K and we allow the
operation which we had before of the sum
over the set C of GNH right I'm also
going to define another operation this
slightly syntactic which takes a graph G
which has these additional constants and
it raises the name CI you can forget
some ok then the tree decomposition can
be seen for any graph of tree with ok
you you can get it by starting with
graphs with at most K plus 1 vertices
and a sequence of these two operations
you the eraser operation is basically
you forget the names of vertices so that
when you take the disjoint some you're
not going to use them and this sum takes
the two graphs GNH while identifying the
ones named by constants ok
so a sequence of these operations gives
you any graph of treatment at most K and
now what is this all all of this have to
do with MSL well the point is the eraser
operation it's very easy to see is also
this T equivalence is a congruence with
respect to this for the simple you're
doing is forgetting information right so
if two graphs are MSOP equivalent so
here Row one is there an interpretation
of a constants the map from the
constants to okay at most K plus 1
vertices then so is this
the disjoint sum over a set see we've
already seen is it this MSO equivalents
P equivalence is a congruence for that
and therefore we can give in a graph and
a tree decomposition of it given an MSL
formula of quantify rank P we can turn
the formula into an automaton which
works up or works on the bottom up
decomposition of the graph again the
states of the automata are the
equivalence classes of this equivalence
relation and we can compute the type of
the tree this is the essence of course
else theorem which basically says given
any MSL sentence and fixed K there is a
linear time algorithm linear in the size
of the graph which for any graph of tree
with at most K decides whether the graph
satisfies Phi so we can translate Phi
into a linear time algorithm basically
the idea is you translate the formula
into a bottom up tree automaton the size
of the automaton doesn't depend upon the
graph because it's this number of states
is simply the number of p equivalence
classes repears the quantifier rank of
Phi there are things you need which I
haven't really said you need to be able
to do first of all from the tree compute
the tree decomposition okay that I
haven't told you at all how to do that's
a difficult dialect ask in itself but it
turns out you can do it and here you
need also of course that you can compute
this automaton from Phi ok well I mean
for the statement as I've given it you
don't because all I'm saying is there
exists an algorithm I'm not saying that
the algorithm can be computed but in
fact you can okay and you can come get
this automaton from this and then it
accepts so from G computer label treaty
that's the tree decomposition from the
formula you compute the automaton and
then you run the automaton on this label
tree and it tells you whether or not the
original graph satisfies the formula
okay I think this is a I mean there's a
lot of work that goes into this theorem
and I think of I was trying to convey
some of the flavor of it maybe if it's
got a bit technical so I think maybe
this is the point where I'll stop and
let you take a breather okay questions
actually we know in the parameters K and
the formula Phi is what's okay it's
single exponential minus Phi is non
elementary right so I mean when I say
when Phi so I mean here you could yeah
so P the quantifier rank of Phi it's not
elementary in P that's right so if you
fix the formula Phi so the only thing
that really depends on K is this
computation and that's exponential in K
but linear in G yes
okay
all right well thank you and we break
for lunch back at 1:30